für ihr im zentrum hat sich die stadt
düsseldorf gleich ein ganzes
fußballstadion ausgesucht schaulaufen
fürs impfen
der bundesgesundheitsminister und der
ministerpräsident geimpft wird nicht auf
dem rasen sondern in den innenräumen so
der plan
die könnten quasi schon mit check-in und
anderen heute hier starten das muss
überall im land gewährleistet sein denn
es darf keine sekunde verzug sein wenn
der impfstoff kommt in hamburg
begutachtet der erste bürgermeister die
aufbauarbeiten seines zentrums in einer
großen messehalle
wir sehen heute dass es gut voran geht
wir wollen am 15 12 fertig sein hier
startklar sein mit allem in berlin lädt
die gesundheitssenatorin zum
pressetermin in eine eventarena und
verbreitet optimismus wir haben sehr
früh schon in berlin angefangen mit den
planungen von impfzentren und damit wir
auch wenn der impfstoff kommt start
bereits sind das war am vergangenen
donnerstag damals standen vier kabinen
jetzt sind sie wieder weg sie waren nur
kulisse für die pressevorführung
immerhin die strom- und datenkabel gibt
es schon
eigentlich soll in einer woche alles
fertig sein damit hier täglich 4000
menschen geimpft werden können
albrecht broemme ehemaliger chef des
technischen hilfswerks ist für den
aufbau der impfzentren in berlin
verantwortlich was wichtig wird sein
dass in einem geordneten strom natürlich
nach der einlasskontrolle registrierung
die impflinge hier vorgehen und dieser
bereich der hier mit einem bodenbelag
versehen werden wird ist der bereich wo
dann auch die im kabinen aufgestellt
werden
sie werden etwa 80 im kabinen stehen
bis zum 15 dezember sollen alle
impfzentren stehen das haben die
gesundheitsminister versprochen schafft
berlin das wenn ich den 15 dezember als
mittel nehme ist das ein sehr
anspruchsvolles ziel was weiß ich ja
nicht ganz erreichen
aber mitte dezember ist ja auch noch die
mittel ist die mitte das ist ein etwas
breiter bereich schauen wir mal
die zeit drängt denn schon bald soll es
in deutschland den impfstoff geben der
von kogit 19 schützt der wurde in
rekordzeit entwickelt und getestet
viele patienten sind deshalb
verunsichert wie in dieser berliner
arztpraxis
ich würde erstmal abwarten wie die
impfungen überhaupt laufen und ob es
irgendwelche komplikationen
möglicherweise gibt
ich würde schon etliche wochen warten
vorsichtig vielleicht wenn ich junge wir
probieren aber ich bin ein bisschen den
fortgeschrittenen alter und
bin ich ein bisschen eher vorsichtig und
dann würde ich sagen welchen ab wagner
mal sehen wie die ergebnisse sind dr
kreischa versteht ihre bedenken er ist
überzeugt der impfstoff ist entscheidend
im kampf gegen das virus doch viele
fragen seien noch offen
das ist ein impfstoff der neue ist da
können wir nicht auf erfahrungen
zurückblicken wie beispielsweise bei
masern impfungen bei tetanus info oder
bei grippe impfung ich hoffe dass die
vorbereitung ausreichend sein wird was
wir natürlich nicht überschauen können
das ist die wirkung dieser info klar
steht fest jetzt schon dass man auch
nach der impfung muss sich schützen muss
das heißt wir werden nicht auf mund und
nasenschutz masken verzichten denn ob
ein corona impfstoff eine übertragung
des virus verhindert ist noch ungewiss
der impfstoff von biontech und pfizer
ist der erste der in deutschland
zugelassen werden soll
die hersteller beziffern die wirksamkeit
auf bis zu 95 prozent
professor evers ist mitglied der
ständigen impfkommission die hat die
studienergebnisse von beyond eckpfeiler
ausgewertet weil impfstoff weiß man
jetzt das in der gruppe keine schweren
nebenwirkungen aufgetreten sind wohl
aber eine ganze menge
und wirklich eine ganze menge
sogenannter leichter impfreaktionen das
heißt einfach dass menschen schmerzen an
der impfstelle hatten oder fieber hatten
oder kopf- oder gliederschmerzen hatten
und es ist etwas was dann nach ein paar
tagen auch wieder verschwindet also
nicht per se schwerwiegend ist die
ständige impfkommission empfiehlt in
welcher reihenfolge in deutschland die
menschen geimpft werden sollen
der allergrößte risiko faktor ist
tatsächlich das alter nach allem was man
weiß springen alle anderen
vorerkrankungen die es da so gibt
gegenüber ja dem alter weit in den
hintergrund
zuerst sollen deshalb die über
80-jährigen geimpft werden und besonders
gefährdetes medizinisches personal
wer eine vorerkrankung hat und geimpft
werden will muss sich einer test beim
arzt besorgen
so steht es im referentenentwurf für die
korona virus im verordnung
darin heißt es risikogruppen haben
anspruch auf ausstellung eines
ärztlichen zeugnisses über das bei ihnen
vorliegende krankheitsbedingt erhöhte
risiko für einen schweren oder tödlichen
krankheitsverlauf in bezug auf die
korona viruskrankheit 2009 10
wir zeigen dr kreisstadt das interne
papier aus dem gesundheitsministerium
also mein eindruck ist dass es mit
heißer nadel gestrickt worden es wurde
nicht mit den beteiligten gesprochen
zumindest nicht mit uns hausärzte und
hiernach sollen wir in den praxen die
patienten mit risiko mit risiko
krankheiten ausfällt dann zusätzlich
sollen wir für diese patienten atteste
ausstellen
das wird ein großer aufwand werten und
ich hoffe dass wir den praxisbetrieb
darum da trotzdem durchführen können
deutschland hat sich insgesamt 70
millionen impfdosen von biontech weiter
gesichert wie viele davon schon zu
beginn der emphase zur verfügung stehen
werden ist offen
kaiser musste schon
lieferschwierigkeiten einräumen
nachfrage beim bundesgesundheitsminister
am vergangenen freitag
das gab meldungen der pfizer biotech
deutlich weniger impfstoff produzieren
können als ich zunächst angekündigt
haben da ist die rede von der hälfte was
bedeutet das für deutschland das führt
dazu dass alle die sozusagen unter den
ersten adressen der lieferungen sind ob
es großbritannien die usa oder die
europäische union ist jetzt mit weniger
impfungen in den ersten oder impfdosen
in den ersten wochen zu rechnen haben
gleichwohl wird es stand heute wenn die
zulassung erfolgt mit dem jahreswechsel
erste impfungen in deutschland geben
können
das heißt selbst wenn es pünktlich los
geht wird es noch länger dauern bis
genügend menschen geimpft sind um die
pandemie zu besiegen
nur eine von vielen baustellen